I got a call yesterday from a talmid,
a guy who was learning in yeshiva here
last year, got married and made aliyah, and
he is coming back to America for Yom
Tov to be with his parents for Yom
Tov. And he wanted to know how to
handle being a Ben Eretz Yisrael in chutz
la'aretz for Yom Tov. Now, he's a legitimate
Ben Eretz Yisrael, not one of these people
that have been living in America for 15
years, but still talks on the phone on
Yom Tov Sheini because they're talking in Hebrew.
He's a legitimate Ben Eretz Yisrael, and he's
going to be in chutz la'aretz for Yom
Tov. So, he wants to know how does
he navigate the circumstance. So the Gemara, Masechet
Beitza, daf daled amud bet, tells us that
even though we know what the right calendar
day is, avdinan trei yomei mishum deshalkhu mitam
hizaru beminhag avoteichem beyadeichem. Though we have minhag
avoteichem beyadeichem, we have to still observe Yom
Tov Sheini shel Galuyos in chutz la'aretz. The
mishnah in the fourth perek of Masechet Pesachim
tells us that if you go from somewhere
that does melachah on Erev Pesach to somewhere
that doesn't do melachah on Erev Pesach, nosnu
lo chumrei makom sheyatza misham vechumrei makom shehalach
lesham, veal yeshaneh adam mipnei hamachlokes. People should
not behave differently, they should take the chumros
of both places where they came from and
went to. They shouldn't behave differently from the
people around them in a more meikel than
them because that will cause machlokes. So commenting
on that mishnah, the Gemara on daf nun-aleph
amud bet going up to nun-bet amud aleph
says that if a Ben Eretz Yisrael goes
to chutz la'aretz for Yom Tov, they should
not do melachah beyishuv because of machlokes, but
in the midbar it's muttar. So in the
yishuv they're not allowed to do melachah, but
in the midbar it's muttar to do melachah.
And that's why the Shulchan Aruch paskens in
siman taf-tzadi-vav seif gimmel: Bnei Eretz Yisrael sheba'u
lechutz la'aretz asurim la'asos melachah beyom tov sheini
beyishuv, afilu da'ato lachazor. They cannot do melachah
even if they plan on going right back
to Eretz Yisrael after Yom Tov in a
Jewish community. Vechol zeman shelo higia leyishuv, afilu
ein da'ato lachazor, muttar lefi she'adayin lo hukba
lihyos kemosan. But so long as they have
not yet gotten to the yishuv, even if
they don't plan on going back, they are
not yet kavua as Bnei Chutz la'aretz until
they get into a Jewish community and therefore
they still retain the status of Bnei Eretz
Yisrael. So if they're in a midbar somewhere
and they arrived on Yom Tov Sheini, or
they arrived before Yom Tov and stayed through
Yom Tov Sheini, they do not yet have
to observe an issur melachah. So what about
melachah done in private? So, right, so clearly
melachah done in public is asur, that's befeirush
in the Gemara, that's befeirush in the Shulchan
Aruch. What about a melachah done in private?
So Tosafos in Masechet Pesachim writes: Beyishuv lo
avdinan afilu betzina, ve'afilu da'ato lachazor, delo efshar
lemelachah betzina kishar devarim. melachah is never really
betzina, you'll always be able to find someone
will see, someone will catch on to something,
it's never really betzina. The Ran says no,
the only reason the Gemara was machmir was
it was talking about a very public type
of melachah. So a melachah like writing or
sewing, something that can be done very quietly
and privately, that you could do betzina on
Yom Tov Sheini. The Rambam and the Rif
seem to assume like the Ran. In halachah,
there's a machlokes haposkim. The Taz in siman
taf-tzadi-vav sifei-katan chaf quotes a Maharshal in Yam
Shel Shlomo in the first perek of Masechet
Beitza who seems to be meikel on this.
And then the Taz writes: Ein lo lehakel
befanenu vela'asoso chol. You shouldn't certainly be meikel
in public, but in private you can. So
even though the wording of the Taz might
be understood to be talking about how to
dress and putting on tefillin, but if you
look in the Maharshal, he clearly is about
melachah. The Maharshal is meikel about melachah betzina.
But the Magen Avraham on the other hand
holds that even melachah betzina is asur. And
the Mishnah Berurah in taf-tzadi-vav sifei-katan tet says
that it's afilu betzina asur, but im asah
melachah ein menadin oso. That you do have
what to rely on, so you don't have
to go nuts if a guy does melachah
betzina, but lehalachah he shouldn't even do melachah
betzina. Now are there any exceptions? So one
exception is what we mentioned, if a person's
not in yishuv. Shulchan Aruch says that if
he doesn't arrive in the yishuv, he's not
restricted from melachah. And the Mishnah Berurah defines
yishuv is nikra yishuv Yisrael davka. But once
you're within the tchum, you're already considered within
that city, you're already considered within the yishuv.
But if you have somewhere far out to
go where there are no Jewish people, so
and that's where he is for the entirety
of Yom Tov, so then gezuntheit, let him
let him do melachah even, you know, not
betzina, let him it's I guess by definition
it's betzina, let him do melachah on Yom
Tov on Yom Tov Sheini. What about when
it comes to performing mitzvos? So we do
not assume like the Alter Rebbe in Shulchan
Aruch HaRav who says: Ki eis ratzon shelemala
veyichudim elyonim shebikrias Shema utfillah ukedushas Shabbos veYom
Tov hu lemala migeder hamakom vehazeman, rak me'ir
lemata lechol makom umakom zemano hara'ui lo. Vezehu
gam kein hata'am sheshora kedusha elyona bechutz la'aretz
beyom sheini shel galuyos. That the Alter Rebbe
writes that it's all depends on where you
are and there is a a presence presence
of actual kedusha on Yom Tov Sheni Shel
Galuyos in Chutz La'aretz. velachen gam bnei eretz
yisrael haba'im lechutz la'aretz chayavim bikedushas hayom af
sheda'atam lachzor, meaning the Alter Rebbe's kula on
the other end of bnei Chutz La'aretz going
to Eretz Yisrael only having to keep one
day because it's talya in being in Eretz
Yisrael is a chumra on this end. Right?
He holds that bnei Eretz Yisrael who come
to Chutz La'aretz mamash have two days of
Yom Tov because it's talya in the makom.
So we generally do not pasken that way.
I imagine that in Chabad they do, but
we generally do not pasken that way. Mishnah
Berurah in seif katan yod-gimmel says that when
it comes to tefillin, tzrichim hem lehispallel tfillas
shmoneh esrei belachash b'yom tov sheni v'chen lehani'ach
tfillin betzina kivan sheda'ato lachzor. They should wear
tefillin betzina but not publicly. Certainly assure Yom
Tov clothing on Yom Tov Sheni. When they
put the tefillin on, they should say Krias
Shema and then take the tefillin off and
daven Shmoneh Esrei with the tzibur. Shemiras Shabbos
Kehilchasa quotes Rav Shlomo Zalman Auerbach that you
could even daven Shmoneh Esrei at home with
the tefillin on because more important to daven
Shmoneh Esrei with tefillin on than to daven
tefillah b'tzibur. I just had a chassan last
night and I saw a ben Eretz Yisrael
there who's going to be in Chutz La'aretz
for Yom Tov. He told me that he
would go to Rav Neuburger's shul and he
would go into the nursing room, the room
that mothers were nursing and he would daven
at the vasiqin minyan. I said how do
you know there's not going to be a
nursing woman there? He said it's a vasiqin
minyan, probably not. So he would and he
would put on tefillin there and close the
door and leave it open just a crack
so he could be davening together with the
tzibur. I don't know that you have to
do that. I mean I'm pretty sure you
don't have to do that, but that's a
nice nice chumra I guess. When it comes
to tefillah, they should daven a weekday tefillah
and certainly say Atah Chonantanu in the Maariv
after the first day of Yom Tov. There's
a discussion in poskim if you have ten
bnei Eretz Yisrael should they make their own
minyan? So the B'tzel HaChochmah Rav Betzalel Stern
says yes. In Yom Tov Sheni Kehilchaso he
quotes Rav Shlomo Zalman and Rav Elyashiv that
say no. Rav Sternbuch in Teshuvos VeHanhagos Chelek
Alef Siman Reish-Mem-Ches has a compromise. He says
if the second day of Yom Tov is
Shabbos, yes. If the second day of Yom
Tov is not Shabbos, then no, then they
should not make their own separate minyan. Why,
what difference does it make? He says because
the whole reason they shouldn't make their separate
minyan is it's a zilzul to Yom Tov
Sheni. But you know what's an even higher
level of kedusha than Yom Tov Sheni? Shabbos.
So if they're making a Shabbos minyan, so
then it's even better than Yom Tov Sheni,
so that's not a problem, says Rav Sternbuch.
The Shevet HaLevi Chelek Zayin Siman Samech-Heh writes
that hapsheetu on the ben Eretz Yisrael in
Chutz La'aretz has to say Havdalah Motzaei Yom
Tov Rishon shelo that it's muttar lehadlik ner
Havdalah that even though you're not allowed to
do melachah, but if you need ner Havdalah
you gotta light the ner Havdalah. Now when
it's Yom Tov and you can light miner
l'ner so certainly you could do that anyone
can light miner l'ner so they're allowed to
light a ner Havdalah miner l'ner is probably
the way to do it. The Shevet HaLevi
Chelek Zayin Siman Samech-Heh also writes that yeira'eh
d'hai piska lehachmir gam betzina derech safeik lehachmir
nishneh velo derech vadai. He has a yesod.
He says the idea that we're machmir like
the Magen Avraham that even betzina is assur,
that's only mishum safeik. It's not betoras vadai.
And therefore by some of the more lighter
issurim maybe we could be meikel such as
shevisas behemah, muktzah, things like that, he says
you could be meikel because it's only mishum
safeik, it's not betoras vadai. In the sefer
Piskei Teshuvos he quotes a different sevara that
I later found he's actually just quoting from
the same Shevet HaLevi earlier in the teshuvah
that anything that could be done in a
muttar way you can do because people will
assume you're doing it in the muttar way.
So he says you're allowed to be metaltel
muktzah let's say a kli shemelachto l'issur because
everyone will assume oh it's probably letzorech gufo
v'tzorech mekomo. It's not letzorech gufo v'tzorech mekomo
but no one else knows that. So anything
that could be interpreted to be done in
a muttar way, so you're allowed to do
on Yom Tov Sheni if you're a ben
Eretz Yisrael. Mishnah Berurah in seif katan yod-gimmel
says that if the second day of Yom
Tov is Friday, ein tzarich l'areiv eiruvei tavshilin
mipnei shehu davar shebetzina. They don't need to
make an eiruv tavshilin because that's a davar
shebetzina that's fine. And it's not a melachah.
As far that's hachana. As far as turning
on lights, fascinating discussion. Rav Moshe in Igros
Moshe Orach Chaim Chelek Daled Siman Kuf-Daled raises
a question. He says kivan d'ein b'hav'arah l'ha'ir
babayis issur mitzad melachah b'Yom Tov. On Yom
Tov turning on a light is not really
melachah. It's an issur of nolad that you're
molid esh which is not a melachah, it's
only nolad miderabbanan. But on the other hand
the entire issur is not to be meshaneh
mipnei hamachlokes which lichora should apply to derabbanans.
So Rav Moshe writes that we should asser
for a ben Eretz Yisrael to turn on
electric lights because it's not and he says
especially since it's not really shayeich betzina because
everyone's going to realize that the light's turned
on and it could be seen from a
great distance. So it should be like tzina
which we're machmir about. But then he says
I don't know. ela kivan d'beharbeih batim ika
sha'onim k'eilu shemadlikin umechabin neiros hachashmal. He said
but there are timers on lights. So just
because a light went on and off on
Yom Tov it doesn't necessarily tell you that
anyone did anything. Right? So maybe since it's
not a melacha and there are timers on
lights, maybe it's mutar to turn on the
lights betzina on Yom Tov Sheni for a
ben Eretz Yisrael to remember, all this is
about a ben Eretz Yisrael. For a ben
Eretz Yisrael to turn on the lights betzina
on Yom Tov Sheni. In the Sefer Yom
Tov Sheni Kehilchaso, he quotes Rebbi First that
Rav Moshe thought that we might be able
to be meikel because heicha shelo olam lo
yehey pirsum efshar shein zeh bekhlal gezeiras Yom
Tov Sheni. No one will ever know, it
looks like a timer. So Rav Shlomo Zalman
is quoted as aser turning on the lights,
and certainly according to the Chazon Ish, turning
on the lights is a melacha that's boneh,
so for sure you're not allowed to turn
on the lights because then you don't have
the first tzad lehakeil that Rav Moshe has,
that the whole thing is only nolad midirabbanan.
Rav Schachter told us a story here in
Washington Heights, he said that there was a
visiting professor or something whose wife was ill
and needed treatment in a hospital, and Rav
Schachter said he ran into an older lady
from the building who said, \"You know that
professor that pretends he's religious?\" And Rav Schachter
said, \"What do you mean, he's like a
talmid chacham, he's very religious, what are you
talking about?\" So she said, \"Oh no, I
could see when I look out my window,
I see in the reflection of the window
across the street what's going on in his
apartment next to mine, and I sit by
the window all day and I see that
at random times his lights go on and
off on Yontif. So he obviously was a
ben Eretz Yisrael, he was here for Yom
Tov Sheni, and he figured it's betzina and
he's turning on his lights, it's not a
big deal. So Rav Schachter always uses that
story as a ra'ayah that the Mishnah Berurah
is correct that we should be machmir betzina
not to turn on lights. What about showering?
So if you hold that generally you're not
allowed to shower on Yom Tov, the Sefer
Yom Tov Sheni Kehilchaso in the footnote yud-alef
says that since it's possible to shower in
a permissible way, one limb at a time,
the guy can shower because bnei Chutz La'aretz
will assume that he's doing it in a
muttar way. And he says that he asked
Rav Elyashiv and Rav Elyashiv was maskim that
that's okay. One last point, and that is
that when it comes to traveling, a ben
Eretz Yisrael who wants to get back to
Eretz Yisrael might find that there's a cheaper
flight that leaves on Yom Tov Sheni, but
that's assur, right? Meaning he can't go to
the airport because that certainly al yishtaneh mipnei
hamachlokes. When it comes to flying to America
on Yom Tov Sheni, a lot of times
a ben Eretz Yisrael may want to come
in and they'll fly to America on Yom
Tov Sheni, that's muttar provided that he doesn't
go into the yishuv, right? That's b'feirush in
Shulchan Aruch, as long as he doesn't go
into the yishuv, he stays in the airport
or he goes somewhere far away. It's not
abundantly clear to me what happens if you're
not a clear ben Eretz Yisrael that you're
allowed to do that, and I would think
you're not allowed to do that. Meaning, a
lot of times you have people that keep
one day when they're in Yisrael, but not
because they're bnei Eretz Yisrael, because they're following
some, they own an apartment or they're shlosha
regalim, whatever, some shita or combination of shitos
that they're following. But when they're in Chutz
La'aretz, they keep two days and they have
to keep two days. So can they fly
back on the second day of Yom Tov?
I think we once gave a shiur about
that. That's not so clear that you could
say, \"Oh as long as I stay in
the midbar that that's okay. One could make
that argument. I was in Los Angeles recently
and Tzvika Ryzman son told me that that's
what Tzvika tells his children to do, that
they could fly back on Yom Tov Sheni
and just go to one of his properties
somewhere on the outskirts of wherever, and stay
there until after Yontif. I think he told
me that not all the family members follow
the psak, some of them are just not
comfortable doing that, and they'll pay a little
extra for the ticket the next day. But
certainly if you're an actual ben Eretz Yisrael,
you're certainly allowed to do that.